thank you so I decided to talk about
something very specific something really
we did along the way when we were
working on biological problems and the
reason that I chose to talk about this
is obviously I don't want to talk about
decision network diffusion because
anybody's talking about it right but
besides that I really enjoyed doing this
work and I think it is it can be handy
if you are doing in am elated that for
some reason that I don't understand but
so and also I am expecting there
somebody real tell oh this is already
not okay so since we are in a in the
institute for theoretical computer
science my contribution to this project
was really telling shun shun did all the
work and repeatedly telling him that
come on Shan this must have been done
and but i never i was never able to show
him that actually this was done so i
think in that sense it is interesting
and marks contribution was daily mark is
the biological contributor to the
project and his contribution was to keep
reminding him that we want the software
out not the pros so I'm shun did all the
work so and I will I will try to explain
it as much as I can understand from what
Jean did so I will start with the
problem description we have a graph we
have a net way which is usually a
biological network at least you know our
inspiration is that right so we are
talking about a network with thousands
of Ages and ten thousand thousands of
nodes and ten thousands of edges and we
have an objective function to maximize I
mean you can also minimize it but you
know let's focus on maximization so
essentially we want to identify
connected sub graphs that maximize that
objective function that maximal
connected sub graph that satisfy a
quantifiable property essentially that's
our goal so in molecular networks this
is interesting because connected means
functionally related and of course you
can also generalize the notion of
connectivity as well
so we also assume that there is a
bounding function so this can either be
here edit any property or we might be
able to bound the score of a subgraph
given the scores of its sub graphs okay
so the idea is essentially can we use
innovative algorithms or branch and
bound algorithms efficiently if we have
such a bounding function or if it is
edited if the probability that we are
looking at is hereditary so in terms of
the applications I mean I encountered
this problem twice in my life but you
know just to give you an example for
example you can think of this is one
simple example is if you want to
eliminate all maximal cliques in a graph
then you can define the problem in these
terms by just letting the score to be
equal to the size of the sub graph right
and then making it equal to zero if it
is not a click okay so you can map many
different graph problems that require
elimination to this set up so I
encountered this problem first when I
was implementing algorithms for graph
mining in the context of network
alignment but then in the context of
systems biology of cancer we developed
an algorithm which I want to talk about
a little more in detail we're here we
were trying to identify groups of
function related proteins such that at
the gene expression level when we look
at the binary gene expression profiles
that escapes a specific States of the
sub graph provide information about the
phenotype so we we baby describe this we
define the scoring function in terms of
the mutual information by decomposing
the mutual mutual information between
the state of a sub graph and the
phenotype and then never looking for
essentially subgraphs such that there is
significant statistical dependence
between the state of that sub graph in
terms of the gene expression and then
and the phenotype so the good thing
about this was when we defined the
objective function this way then we were
able to bound the score of his sub graph
of a set of vertices given the scores or
given simple statistics of its smaller
sub graphs so then I mean you know for
these tests you usually develop a greedy
algorithm and it is sufficient right for
the purposes of getting something
biologically significant but we had this
nice bounce so we went ahead and
implemented in a nominative algorithm
and then we implemented the same object
the same optimization problem using a
greedy algorithm and we were able to
show that actually if you do animation
you you can't find sub networks that are
better in terms of performing predictive
tasks as opposed to the greedy algorithm
so there we were able to show that yes
actually doing more than greedy
algorithm searching beyond greedy
algorithms can be useful so then we went
ahead and also applied this algorithm to
glioblastoma finding markers of survival
engler blastoma and they were they were
validated at the protein level as well
so we were able to identify proteins
that are not measured in terms of
protein but in terms of protein
expression but we were able to go ahead
and read a test them in the lab and see
that actually we can pick up these
proteins that don't show up in the gene
expression data but when we applied this
algorithm we can pick those up and
they're indeed differentially expressed
at the protein level so we were really
happy with this algorithm bit one
problem it was implemented in MATLAB in
a rush so this was done by Salem
chaudhary so sillon did a great job
developing this algorithm but he
implemented it so that he can test it
quickly so it was a mess that only
people who really knew what was going on
could use it so we wanted to implement
it in such a way that it but even you
know the domain scientists can use
so that was chance test tion was test by
implementing this algorithm in a clean
way so that everybody can use it but
then tion notice something and you know
the actually I mean this is if you think
about it you will observe this
immediately saw in the origin in our
original implementation we've
eliminating the sub graphs in depth
first order and then you enumerate the
sub graphs in the first order you can't
issue the fourth condition here which is
actually really but you need if you want
to efficiently use an enumerator
algorithm essentially what it says is if
I will use a bounding function right to
prune out subgraphs without tasting them
then I need to generate and evaluate all
sub graphs of a given sub graph before i
generate any related sub graph so that i
can really use this pruning efficiently
and if you eliminate sub graphs in their
first order obviously you can't do that
ok the rest of the conditions that we
specified a really we figured them out
which on those are kind of obvious
essentially you want to generate
everything possible right because you
are developing an inter- algorithm
second you don't want an overhead in the
sense that if you will generate a set of
nodes you want them to be connected you
don't want to generate a set and then
check whether they are connected and
third you don't want any redundancy
meaning that you want to generate
everything exactly once not more than
once and it's a difficult thing to do
when you are eliminating sub graphs
right everybody who dealt with sub
browse know that very well so
essentially diving into the main problem
we call it a talent rejection then the
happen today it has the sub graph that
is not actually promising so if we could
be able to eliminate a sub graph without
even generating it but we happen to
generate it then the city down on track
rejection so we want to get rid of
redundant rejections completely but if
it is not possible we at least want to
minimize the number of redundant
rejections so this is the problem set up
so again you know when Sean came up with
beside you I kept telling him that all
shun this is so fundamental that it must
be done it must have been done so we
looked at it look at looked at it looked
at it again I talked to a few people so
essentially these are the obvious values
of eliminating subgraphs of a graph
right you can either do bread first
elimination which is good because which
will satisfy all the conditions that all
the properties that we decide but it
will be very costly in terms of memory
if you generate subgraphs inbred first
order then you will have to remember
everything that you generated before you
start combining them and it is not
feasible not use these are induced
subgraphs so you are generating sets
essentially the constraint that they are
connected
now if you do it in that first tour that
then it's very efficient in terms of
memory you don't really need to keep
anything right but it badly fails
optimal optimal order of elimination
because since you do it in that first
order only one sub graph of a sub graph
will be generated and indeed craft sub
graph will be generated all other sub
graphs will be generated after that so
then when I talk to people on how this
can be done almost everybody said oh
yeah you can do it using reverse search
and at that point I noticed when we
looked at reverse search I noticed that
this is probably why people didn't pay
attention to this problem before because
reverse search really does it but it
does it if the graph is small right and
sparse d is not a concern here we are
dealing with graphs where we have
thousands of nodes and ten thousands of
Ages reverse search does not take into
account sparsity it generates subsets
and then checks for connectivity if you
do it with a protein interaction network
where you have thousands of nodes the
subset space is much larger than they
connect the sub graph space because of
connectivity so you can't apply the
curses reverse search so the algorithm
dates undeveloped and we put again you
know we published this in alcove if you
are familiar with the conference I don't
know now it is drag going into its third
year it's a new european conference in
algorithms in computational biology so
they published it in the first year of
that conference and I we moved on I mean
son doesn't want to do anything beyond
this point but the two contributions of
his algorithm was first idea of using
anchor burgesses to simplify the problem
i will explain that and second using a
hybrid of that first and bread first
enumeration so that he can guarantee
that we generate the sub graphs in the
optimal order of enumeration without
compromising in of the other constraints
constraints that we have so the two men
operations in his algorithm our
extension and cloning so the use of
anchor vertices is actually is quite
simple it compromises the optimal order
of a minimization actually okay but it
simplifies the problem a lot so
essentially what you're saying is
instead of trying to generate all
connected subgraph I will generate all
connected sub graphs that contain a
given vertex when you do that then
checking for connectivity becomes very
easy because you have an anchor vertex
that connects everything so by doing a
search through that vertex you can
eliminate all connected sub graphs
really quickly and amongst you are done
with that vertex you can remove that
vertex and its edges and repeat this
process again again this compromises the
optimal or drop enumeration obviously
right but you can heuristic leeches the
order of the vertices that you use as
the anchor to minimize the effect
so then I will I will really explain
this between the boundaries of my
intellectual capacity whenever shank
came to me always the discussion would
go like I would explain I will I will
tell him okay son let me understand what
we are doing and I would explain to him
as I will explain to you now and then he
would correct me again and again but you
know this is what i understand and i
still believe that i get the spirit of
it but i think there are some nuts and
bolts that only jean can explain so
offensive the idea is this so if we
simplify the problem is just animal
eating all the sub graphs that contain
the immediate neighbors of a given not
so given notice a here and i just want
to go generate all the sub cross that
contain a and its immediate neighbors
then this is just you this computer
using a binomial three right so the
entire algorithm is based on this
observation so now the order in which
you generated binomial three is you
first in lexicographic order you first
add one of the vertices n-able rate okay
then you ate the second vertex is a
child and evaluate and then you can't
you clone the previous branches and at
that point you evaluate and if you will
reject the sub graph you rejected a bit
point and then now when you add the
third vertex when you clone it the sub
graphs that you generate are already
prone sabras so this is the main idea so
this also gives rise to two types of
branches depth branches and bred
branches we're dead fred branches are
those that are generated by extension
right those are the immediate neighbors
of our anchor not where is the bread
branches are those that are created by
cloning meaning that the connectivity is
inferred because they are connected
through our anchor vertex so the
classification of the depth-first dead
branches and great branches turns out to
be important when you are proved trying
to prove the properties of this
algorithm because essentially using
those that and bred branches you can
classify the different cases you will
run into in the case of cycles and
things like that so but this is only
again for the problem of generating all
set subsets of the immediate neighbors
of a given not but it turns out it it's
very easy to generalize this so now once
you generate all those of the debt
binomial 3 but you can do is for each
branch each brand each internal node
industry represents a specific sub graph
so when you are extending from that not
all you need to do is really take
consider that sub graph is a vertex in
the graph and repeat the same thing and
here comes the nuts and bolts that again
tion explains every time but you know I
will keep it bit here so you can
generalize this again by just you know
recursively applying this idea in evaded
you trade each sub graph is a vertex in
the graph so based on this algorithm we
were able to prove that you know this
algorithm satisfy the basic properties
like it is complete it doesn't have any
redundancy doesn't have any overhead and
second we were able to prove it we can't
guarantee that there won't be any ground
rejections but we can guarantee that
there are no redundant rejections for a
given anchor vertex so if you frame the
question is I want to enumerate all sub
graphs that contain a given vertex then
we can guarantee that there will be no
redundant rejections then you can
enumerate the grass in the correct order
so to test whether you know this pays
off whether really if minimizing
redundant rejections helps with anything
we came up with a very simple set up a
very simple toy problem
so lethal we took the human creepy I
network from HP ID and also a citation
network from archives to get an ideal
what's going on both of them here like
in the order of thousands of nodes and
in the order of ten thousands of edges
and the problem that we define this we
assign random lates to the vertices and
then we are looking for maximal sub
graph such that the total weight doesn't
exceed a given threshold so get this set
up what we can do is but if by playing
with the standard deviation of the node
weights we can adjust the difficulty of
the problem and then by playing with the
mean of this distribution and the
threshold we use we can play with the
size of the output how many sub graphs
this will return so this gave us full
control on the problem essentially so if
the problem is easy if the Nord weights
are not very different then as you can
see you won't gain much compared to that
first elimination if you use an
algorithm like ours but if the problem
gets more and more difficult we started
seeing the difference so here
essentially we are plating the fraction
of redundant rejections is a function of
the threshold so if the threshold goes
up the problem gets easier in the sense
that there will be more and more sub
graphs that will be eliminated so is the
threshold gets lower and lower each of
the problem is more difficult and bear
actually the earnings I'll even more as
same for dark I'm network essentially we
see a huge gap between when the problem
is difficult we see a huge gap between
their first elimination versus this
principled enumeration that shall
develop
so this also translates into run time
again you know when we look at the
runtime is a function of the threshold
we see that the runtime goes up is a
function of threshold by the way right
but the Sean's algorithm does much
better than the first animation so then
we also went back to the biological
problem that was inspiring for this work
and you know at the time and we
published the results of crane on
glioblastoma we used the original
implementation it was a depth-first
search their first elimination
implementation so by using the same
setup we asked the question if we did it
using shanz algorithm how efficient
would it be and it turned out that
actually and you know this is as you can
see this algorithm takes quite a bit of
time but the Chancellor thinly improved
runtime quite a bit so it's a nice this
doesn't have to be real time or anything
I think you can say cliff you can afford
to you spend a little time but as you
can see for many instances the this
improvement can make the algorithm
feasible applicable so the conclusion is
we have an algorithm to eliminate all
connected subgraph specifically did
satisfy a little appropriately that's
quantifiable it outperforms that first
elimination so for example in this
context of craft mining depth first
elimination is still the state of the
art so you can use it this instead and
madman question remains open and I don't
know the answer to this question can you
really completely eliminated on many
rejections because we changed the
problems definition elidel to be able to
eliminate redundant rejections so I
would like to thank sean for this work
and I really enjoy working with him he
always comes up with this really nice
ideas and forces me to think about
Theory when I am always busy with
biology and you know Mark for giving us
really inspiring biological problems i
would like to thank my other students
who have contributed to this work or
another way and then again feeling was
the first person who developed the
algorithm detected gave rise to this
problem and then i would also like to
thank all of the coffle all of our
collaborators including roddick here and
i thank him for doing a great job
describing our joint joint work present
in our joint work together so thank you
very much and i am happy to answer your
questions and by the way one one thing
that i forgot to note is actually Fabio
he will be presenting right in recom an
algorithm that solves a specific problem
but they compare their algorithm against
a nomination and they use this algorithm
for enumeration so they took the time to
understand this algorithm and implement
this algorithm instead of implementing a
inefficient enumeration algorithm is a
straw man so congratulations to them and
I was really happy to I was really able
to see that
yeah my student would be presenting it
is the one that i prevented they are you
answer questions i have actually a
question do you and any of the very fast
do you ever beat DFS so it was like when
they get when you get you do really well
against DFS when it's a harder problem
in terms of complexity when it gets very
very easy looks like you're almost
exactly DFS did you see that in any
other examples or most examples was that
always the case I think it's always the
case because when it is easy there is
nothing to prune out essentially it's
the problem so actually when it is easy
it is not easy in terms of the
computational time and you just need to
do it
let's they met again